would you be interested in an assassin's
creed television series well that sounds
like it's happening thanks to a reddit
AMA with the head of content for the
Assassin's Creed series I'm Matt and
this is your hood wearing and neck
stabbing game spot news update
Assassin's Creed head of content Amara's
easia confirmed that a show is in the
works but he didn't divulge any
specifics about it
Ubisoft CEO Iggy Moe since last year
that the company wasn't talks with
Netflix for a series but he didn't say
which property would be spun into a show
it's possible that Assassin's Creed will
get the Netflix treatment you know
because it is one of Ubisoft most
popular franchises but nothing has been
confirmed as of this moment we haven't
seen a new game in the series since
2015's Assassin's Creed syndicate 2016
marked the first year without an
assassin's Creed games in 2009 but we
expect to see the next entry sometime
this year
it's reportedly set in Egypt that is
supposed to be a complete revamping of
the series it's said to feature a
Witcher feel with player progression and
freeform combat we'll keep you updated
as mores confirmed so make sure to LIKE
and subscribe but if you want an
expansive and free roaming adventure
right now check out the latest episode
of reboot in which we discuss how Zelda
breath of the wild set a new benchmark
for open worlds in video games